Peter pan doesn't grow up.
He doesn't establish a relationship with Wendy who's actually real.
He has to settle for Tinkerbell who you know is a ferry and they don't exist.
And so she's really in some sense of figure of his imagination because he won't
mature,
he can't have an actual relationship with,
with a genuine person.
So we have to satisfy himself with,
while it's something like a fantasy actually.
So seriously it is.
It is like that.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's a toned down a lot in the movie version obviously,
but still,
that's what's underlying it.
Now you might say,
well why doesn't Peter Pan want to grow up?
And the answer is the only figure of authority that's around for him is his
captain Hook.
And he doesn't like Captain Hook.
And that's because captain hook is a tyrant.
He's brutal,
you know,
and he's also a coward because he's,
he's lost a hand already to a crocodile with a clock in its stomach.
That's chaos in time.
You know,
that's the dragon that lives underneath everything.
It's like the basilisk in Harry Potter and now Damn Crocodile's already got a
piece of him,
which is exactly the case.
Like that crocodile has got a piece of me,
you know I'm older than 50 and so time is already God its grip on me.
And you know part of the problem of being adult is that you also have to take
the fact that your finite and limited into account and if you're terrified by
that,
which people tend to be,
then it can easily turn you into a tyrant because you're afraid of everything or
disgusted by everything and you have to ramp up the amount you control it.
And so Peter Pan looks at Captain Hook and he thinks there's no damn way.
That's what I want to end up as.
She's got a bad role model,
you know.
So Captain Hook and Stalin in this sort of devouring monster are good
representations of the negative or tyrannical element of the great father her.
So that's the tyrannical element of the dominance hierarchy.
Captain Hook there at the bottom on the right hand side.
He's quite an interesting character because he's basically a tyrant.
And the Peter Pan Story is very interesting because Peter Pan Pan sorta means
everything.
And Peter Pan is the sort of person who wants to retain the dynamic potential of
childhood.
Because when you're a child you're not anything but you couldn't be anything.
So you're pretty much only potential.
And then you might say,
well why should you sacrifice that potential to become something actual?
Cause in some sense it's actually a limiting process.
So for example,
and I mean this in the most concrete possible way,
you have more neural connections when you're born than you do at any other time
in your life.
And most of those die by the time you're too.
So you go through this tremendous pruning process from when you're born,
from when,
til two so it's like you're dying into your childhood personality.
And then again,
the same thing happens at the end of adolescence between say 16 and 20 when,
which is also the peak time for risk for the emergence of schizophrenia.
And some people think that's the pruning process gone wrong.
You know,
as an adolescent,
you also shed childhood potential to become the limited but specialized in
potentially useful thing that you will become.
And so you might say,
well,
is it worth it?
Is it worth shedding that potential?
And Peter Pan's answer to that is,
well,
no,
he wants to remain in Neverland as a magical boy forever.
And he's king of the lost boys,
which I would say it's not a very,
that's not much of a dominance hierarchy,
right?
It's like you're,
you're the king king of the King of the losers,
so to speak,
people who can't get their act together and mature.
Now.
And you notice in Peter Pan,
the individual is the hero and hero stories and is the initiate an initiatory
routines.
And so the hero is the person who is attempting to become a complete biological
and historical entity personality so that they're capable not only of,
of,
um,
adopting independent existence,
but if adopting independent existence that's productive and that's productive in
a way that's also a benefit to the community.
So it's a particular pattern of development and that that needs to be catalyzed
by human societies.
Because in order for a society to,
to maintain its structure and for the people within it to thrive,
the developing individuals have to mature to the point where they can take care
of themselves in a way that doesn't disrupt the whole social structure.
And so that's the path.
It's a natural path for human beings.
I would say to some degree because we're such intensely social creatures,
but because we're also quite malleable and complex and also grounded in history
and cultural creatures,
it's also something that has to be taught both from the perspective of imitation
and explicitly.
And so a lot of initiation rights for example,
are predicated on the idea that you take the person out of their childhood
context,
you destroy their personality usually as a consequence of some cause,
a traumatic encounter.
And then you refill them with the cultural norms and that makes them an adult.
And so,
you know,
to some degree that's what you guys are doing in a very slow way.
When you make the transition from high school say to university or the
transition from high school to a,
to a job.
We don't,
in our culture,
we don't have the kind of abrupt ceremonies though that are designed to catalyze
that transformation.
And you know,
maybe that's an okay thing and,
and then maybe it's not an okay thing.
I mean,
one of the things that Freud pointed out and he's absolutely right about this,
um,
is that because human beings have such a long dependency period,
it's not that easy for us to grow up.
And sometimes it takes a shock in order for that to happen.
And so one of the boom potential problems with having a dependency period as
long as the human dependency period is that it never ends and that you stay
immature forever.
And really,
I believe that that's the central Eda pulled problem that Freud talked about.
And I believe also that it's a real problem.
Now whether Freud formulated it,
you know,
with precise accuracy,
that's a different story.
But you know,
you've got to give the guy a break.
At least he formulated and,
and,
and it's,
I mean I was much more impressed with Freud and he DePaul theorizing after I did
clinical work for a long time because a large number of my patients,
their primary problem is getting the hell out of their family.
They just can't do it.
And so for them the world is the family.
It's the only thing that matters.
It's often parental opinion or something like that and they just cannot break
free of it.
So,
you know,
initiation ceremonies in part were designed to catalyze that,
that break so that your,
your mother in particular but also your father to some degree,
we're no longer the dominant figures have influenced your,
your personal mother and father were no longer the dominant figures of influence
in your life.
So because really that's what he maturation means in some sense is that when you
become an adult,
the opinions of your parents are as important as the opinions of any other
reasonable people that hypothetically care for you.
But no more important than that.
University is one of those patriarchal institution that's gives with one hand
and takes away with another.
Right.
So when you come here,
there's thousands of you,
there's tens of thousands of view.
So in some sense as an individual you're rather faceless and you're also in some
sense at the bottom of the power hierarchy in the university,
I think more than you should be,
but whatever you,
you are at the bottom of it.
And so there's,
there's a crushing institutional weight that comes along with being part of such
a big university in particular.
You know,
that's really hard on students in their first year.
it's always seemed to me that it's better for first year students to go to a
smaller place where the institutional weight is not so heavy.
And you know,
I've tested u of t students in their first year with things like the Beck
depression inventory and about 30% of u of t students meet criteria for
hospitalized depression.
They do,
you know,
but,
but that's also because the back is way more sensitive to that than it should
be.
At least that you know,
because I don't think its criteria for when you should be hospitalized are
reasonable.
But the point is is that the depression and the anxiety is quite high.
And so,
but on the other hand,
of course you're benefiting from going to university.
And so that's the kind of bipolar nature of the symbol.
It's the tire and intent.
It's benevolent tradition.
At the same time,
you know,
it's molding you.
You could even say it's crushing you because an educational system does that,
but at the same time it's like,
well,
unless you allow yourself to get crushed by it,
you're not going to get the benefit.
And that's the paradoxical relationship that individuals have with culture
everywhere.
And at all time.
You know,
without culture you're nothing but with culture you have to be a cog in some
sense.
And so the tension between those two things is continual and constant.
You could think about it as an existential constant.
Ever since there's been complex human societies and maybe even when there were
only tribal human societies,
that's been a problem for the individual.
So culture,
tradition,
the dominance hierarchy is a solution and a problem and nature.
The unknown,
unexplored territory is a solution and a problem.
And then the third category,
while you see,
I'll just tell you a couple of things about these images.
So the one in the right,
that's the devouring father,
that's also giving birth.
So in some sense,
your personalities are being devoured by the university,
but at the same time,
a new personalities coming emerging as a consequence of that.
And hopefully it's a better personality than the previous one.
If you can tolerate the tension of being transformed,
the heat and the pressure,
then hopefully you come out,
you know,
you come out though,
it's worth it.
The process is worth it.